E aí
[Música]
Eu Sou natural de Santa Cruz vim aqui
para falar um pouco sobre a participação
cívica falando um pouco só a
participação cívica gostaria de dizer
que já tive várias participação porque
faço parte da Associação
Comunitária da minha localidade também
já afundei presidir Associação de
estudantes universitários
Também faço parte de uma Juventude
partidária
participação cívica uma frase muito
bonita e que devia motivar a todos devia
motivar a todos mais só que a maioria
fere atuar no conforto da sua casa no
teu telemóvel os bichos revolucionadas
de teclados portanto dar opinião também
um ato de da participação cívica não
custa na área ver aqui partilhar um
pouco sobre a nossa situação atual em
relação a nossa parte e digo porquê
vê-se claramente que tem vários ganhos
com a nossa participação através de
Ganchos pessoal social e profissional
mas no entanto a nossa juventude que
poderá ser um problema mais ao mesmo
tempo também é uma solução Solução
Porque como é que pode ser problema
solução ao mesmo tempo a se repararem na
na cara frase que que vou citar agora no
final sempre tem a palavra jovem por
exemplo a maior taxa de desemprego é
jovem a maior taxa populacional é jovem
quem é que mais crítica que está sempre
inconformado Jovem quem é mais criticado
é que está sempre a criticar o
criticaram criticado que não quer
trabalhar que não quer estudar que não
quer participar é Nossa Juventude então
isso quer dizer e ao mesmo tempo
poderíamos ser um problema também
poderíamos ter a solução e nós devemos
escolher a parte de fazer Ou seja que
devemos escolher a parte de solucionar
sentar na mesa e tomar a decisão Alguém
já tinha dito que a juventude é o motor
desenvolvimento a e agora estamos a
questionar o desenvolvimento significa
que o motor está avariado
Oi e a maior oportunidade ou seja uma
das melhores oficinas para consertar se
motor são as associações
digo Associação acadêmica Associação
Comunitária e diferente do Faro os mente
Associação de jovens políticos ou seja
político partidário para falar na
associação de estudante talvez alguém
devesse sair uhu vamos ter festa
provavelmente mas não vamos falar da
festa
e vamos falar de integração a integração
durante o processo de transitório da dos
liceus para Universidade ainda é uma dor
de cabeça
porque
precisa-se ter um acolhimento quem é que
não se lembra o seu primeiro semestre da
Universidade
todo mundo perdido a pessoas que
perderam semestre interdentário
encontrar quem é que não se lembra das
corridas desenfreados À Procura da thule
sacaremos serviços ação social
Ou pelo menos os que estudaram aqui em
Cabo Verde ou costura em Cabo ver já
tiveram essa experiência dolorosa
mas bem-aventurados são aqueles que logo
à entrada encontrar uma organização
estudantil pelos acolherem
eu e mais aventurados são aqueles que
participaram nelas digo mais aventurados
porque quando se conhece ou se faz parte
de uma associação acadêmica é uma
oportunidade de conhecer toda a
estrutura da Universidade o edifício e
como é que aquilo funciona e quem faz
parte da universidade tem maior acesso
administração é o privilégio que Todos
deveriam ter para reivindicar para
participar e ajudar naquilo que a gestão
das nossas universidades a relação a
isso passe o contorno experiência porque
as minhas primeiras lados universidades
foram adoráveis
estudava estudava estudava estudava
estudava mas no entanto era mesma coisa
notas negativas creio também que vários
já tiveram essa experiência mas na
verdade não não estrague o Lia e ele ele
ele ia no entanto não funcionava E ao
participar de uma das conferências
Acabei por aprender que estourar e ler e
escrever mas existe uma forma certa para
estudar não existe mas essas dicas
funcionam sempre
se alguém aqui lembra para notas
positivas sem estourar
levante a mão por favor eu também já
tive porque tivemos o privilégio de
durante o processo de estudo primário
secundário os professores ditavam os
professores ditavam nós que sabes mas a
matéria escrevíamos ou seja o período
que se ou e fixem escreve Eu período que
poderíamos ter maior chance de fixar a
matéria na nossa memória de longa
duração
é mas só que na universidade ninguém não
tinha dito que os professores não
estavam
e os professores de onde estou na
universidade é por isso que temos essa
dificuldade logo ao entrar na
universidade e graças à associação de
estudante Acabei por descobrir essa
técnica e com isso acabei por ganhar
gosto pela associação
e depois disso para vocês o aparelho
gosto EA sustentabilidade da associação
acadêmica
e ninguém nos tinha avisar sobre a que
estando
empreendedorismo ou seja um novo
paradigma
o bumbum e nossa sessão Academy Nós
aprendemos como é que ganhamos o
dinheiro aprendemos a reconhecer o
mercado técnicas de marketing quem não
vi não foi base nas universidades quem
não arranjou o maior melhor forma de
cativar os nossos colegas para
participar nos nossos eventos pelo menos
um mês por que encarar mexe pelo menos
uma vez tem um evento ou Hefesto ou
qualquer outro tipo de evento e nesta
oportunidade É Que Nós aprendemos a
vender o nosso país vender nosso produto
ou o nosso serviço Ou pelo menos os
produtores de eventos que conhecem Cabo
Verde na sua maioria esmagadora
participaram da associação de estudantes
e hoje são empresários de sucesso
é também uma coincidência que ele já
seja a maioria deles também participam
ativamente nas atividades comunitárias É
isso que me fez agora falar sobre
associação comunitária é um privilégio
enorme fazer parte da Associação
Comunitária é uma das melhores formas de
participar e conhecer e ajudar
desenvolver sua comunidade e com isso
Nós aprendemos na associações
comunitárias como é que se namora o
projeto e mobiliza os Fundos
internacionais quem é que não gosta de
mobilizar Fundos internacionais todos
nós gostaríamos de imobilizados e isso
no estar da mais credíveis pelo menos
para aqueles que têm estão com a todos
os anos
a transa credibilidade
o e abre o caminho
Estamos ligado diretamente com as
autoridades locais e falando sobre as
autoridades locais Vamos fazer um teste
aqui
e quem é que não faz parte de um partido
político
que não trabalha na nenhuma estrutura do
poder local conhece cinco dos vereadores
dos novos que existem a nossa Câmara
Municipal
levante a mão
o rapaz só conhece o presidente
mas na verdade há vários assuntos são
decididos
a navegação
mais fácil quem é que conhece quatro
deputados municipais de defesa dos dois
partidos que nos representam
a 12
e três quatro
cinco seis sete Mas eu vi várias pessoas
que trabalham trabalhar na Câmara faz
parte invertido ou seja maioria de nós
aqui não conhecemos os nossos
representantes
que é muito grave
estando na associação
comunitária é uma oportunidade de
conhecer as autoridades locais aves o
canal de diálogo
permite a melhor participação
nas decisões do nosso município é esse o
caminho é o benefício que Associação
Comunitária nos oferece
o posto isso
você do advogado de aguardar de feno
ferozmente que os a juventude a ser a
nossa juventude devem fazer parte nos
partidos políticos
devem fundar partidos políticos
e talvez
alguém na plateia podia dizer tá bom
tudo bem
e esse já dar um bom rapaz de repente
entrou na política é mais um
é mas na verdade
nós temos o nosso caráter
ninguém torna-se mal na política
ninguém torna-se bônus na política a
política não faz de ti um homem de
mau-caráter do bom caráter na verdade
isso aprendemos em casa alguém tinha
dito que ocasiões faz-se ladrão é ladrão
sabe mas isto apenas para estava ocasião
é porque eu acredito acredito porque
existe uma cadeira do seja uma cadeira
que se toma de decisão
bom e quando diz bons possíveis
políticos não ocuparem naquela cadeira
ou para eram de Castilho a cadeira curar
será utilizada é oportunidade dos maus
governar os bons e não existe povo bom
lugar de corrupto e não governo corrupto
e povo bom é desta forma que nós
apresentamos Ou seja a oportunidade de
fazer parte
e do jogo e só muda o jogo Quem faz
parte dela
E aí é que entra a juventude partidária
é uma verdadeira escola
Nós aprendemos como é que funciona a
estrutura do por é como é que poderíamos
influenciar forma mais eficaz
e as políticas públicas que recaem sobre
a juventude
é uma das peças fundamentais da nossa
democracia
Quem são os partidos políticos uma sala
de aula pela democracia e vá
e é uma conquista que nós devemos
proteger
eu conheço os partidos políticos
renovam-se os atores aos partidos
mantém-se
ah ah não sei o que vem ao ver uma
ditadura que não faça mais o tanto a
juventude partidária
Eu prometo que um jovem que já fez parte
de ou seja um jovem ativista
que já fez parte da seleção de
estudantes estão Comunitária tem várias
atividades ao entrar na política há uma
discrepância em relação àquele a sua
credibilidade
Oi e a nossa sociedade
deve mudar essa mentalidade
é existe umas um estereótipo muito forte
a relação a isso o líder cuidado com
isso pa é democracia não funciona aquele
uma farsa poderá que ser assim
e talvez não Mas até então é o melhor
modelo que nós temos para governar
Esse é o melhor mulher e nós temos de
acreditar nada
e a participação cívica é o melhor
caminho que a juventude pode escolher
para influenciar nas tomadas de decisões
é o melhor caminho que poderia se
encontrar para sentar na mesa e de
ajudar nós tomar decisões
portanto convido-vos fazem parte das
participações políticas de exportação
sociais das participações comunitárias
porque lá que nós exercemos o nosso por
é muito obrigado
[Aplausos]